you have many great qualities one is
your your very complimentary if you like
someone if you like the way they look
especially women you're not afraid to
march right up to them and say I think
you're very attractive is that is that
the case yeah that's true that is true
women more than men are men as well I
mean yeah - Walter yeah I mean I got
nothing marry so I'm not gonna go up to
some random guy if you like but I do
like I appreciate beauty and yeah I
definitely actually I have a girl crush
and I produce a show on ABC Family
called young and hungry and I play I was
on at the zone I play a lesbian so I
casted her right away
wait there was an actress that you had a
crush on yeah her name is Jessica
Lowndes shoes on 902 know mm-hmm and so
she's always been a girl crush of mine
so being a producer and a boss I got to
cast her as my girl crush and I got to
kiss her
really that was very fun so it's fun for
my husband too yeah also borderline
creepy I'm just gonna say what we're all
thinking you're like yes you appeals to
me yeah you look you want to work then
you will kiss me a name kissing chamber
yeah practice start kissing I think we
have that picture it's now a poster yeah
here we go
that's nice okay take it down
[Music]